hello uh
hello hello rich uh should i keep my i'm
good should i keep my camera on or off
for a minute it's up to you you just
turned it on so you might just leave it
on okay
okay cool uh just a quick question um
i'm about to
uh in the court
and i'm trying to figure out whether i
should stand up with my amber if she
asks for money um the background is it's
not in us the marriage is outside of u.s
and um and if she asked for like hey you
have to give me that much in order to
what do you mean by a amber woman
uh environment like i mean a similar
situation as amber that oh
okay so you're saying that you're
dealing with a narcissist woman yep
okay and she's asking for more than what
she's entitled to
uh she i don't know what she's gonna do
during the court but uh just in case
like if she say hey like you have to pay
me that much in order for me to get
divorced with you and should i just take
it or well no man she doesn't get to
decide what you know you have to pay her
that's what that's what family law is
for but if you want legal advice have
you hired a lawyer where you live like
where do you live
yeah i'm uh in like the south east of
asia okay so you hired a lawyer in in
the country you're in and ask them for
advice yeah
yeah like
basically like
we all have lawyer and we are about to
like go to the court um and i paid her
lawyer and everything and right now it's
just like because you know like like
this kind of women i didn't push too
much to ask for to sign something like
before to go to court to say hey we got
great this so basically i'm not quite
sure what she's gonna do during the
court but uh um i assume like if she's
probably gonna just sign but if she asks
for like hey you have to pay me that
much in order for me to agree to divorce
with you um i was just debating like
whether i should just give in or i
should just fight
because i don't know how nasty is
narcissistic gonna behave in such a way
jonathan what's your experience with
that he's basically asking if you should
take take whatever it is that she's
demanding right now or wait for it to
deal with lawyers and a judge yeah the
your question creates even more
questions like
based on what your net worth is and what
she's asking for and don't tell me
because
somebody's going to need to really do
that analysis because if you're worth a
lot and she's asking for 10 let's say
of uh what that is
maybe it's worth it just to get rid of
her and you're making out great but if
you're not
in that position and she's asking for 90
of what you have well that's another
story so
you've got to run this by a lawyer in
your jurisdiction who can really take a
look at everything the big picture and
decide yep it's worth getting rid of her
if that's her demand i don't know how
much she knows about what you have
or what discovery's been done or any of
that stuff
yeah there's also questions about
whether or not that's going to be
binding because i mean you might you
might give her something that may not be
binding in a long term and she could
take you to court anyway right
yeah well unless it's properly drafted
and executed and incorporated into the
divorce decree but i don't know
even the countries and so somebody local
will be able to give you the best
guidance you'll give them an overview
they'll have a ten thousand foot view of
assets debts how long the marriage is
what you stand to lose if you drag this
out and uh they'll say yeah take it or
not but it's not it's a great question
for your lawyer
yeah
yeah yeah i say thank you jonathan yeah
because i we don't have kids we don't
have common asset everything we're
married long distance so like yeah i
think yeah
how long were you married
uh about like two and a half years you
shouldn't have to give her much if
anything
yeah i i think the same way yeah figure
it out with your lawyer though
okay thank you so much
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you